have that debate about what that top
line number should be it was a meeting
to discuss the u.s military's proposed
773
billion dollar budget for the coming
year the largest in the world by far
it was a meeting where developments in
ukraine overshadowed those discussions
from the leading republican on the
committee an attack on the russian
president for ordering the invasion but
putin's catastrophic invasion of ukraine
has proven to the rest of the world that
he's nothing more than an unhinged
crackpot
the problem is this crackpot has his
finger on the world's largest nuclear
arsenal and illegal stockpile of
chemical and biological weapons
which he hasn't hesitated to use against
his perceived enemies
the us's top general mark millie insists
the actions by russia and the growth in
the chinese military has in his view
made the world a more dangerous place
we are entering a world that is becoming
more unstable
and the potential for significant
international conflict between great
powers is increasing
not decreasing the us has pledged 14
billion dollars to the ukrainians and
military aid important support says the
u.s defense secretary
with help from congress we've been able
to rush security assistance to ukraine
to help the ukrainian ukrainian people
defend their lives and their country and
their freedom
the us still sees china as the biggest
global threat and that's where the
majority of the budget is targeted
progressives hoped a democratic
president would take some defense
spending and pour it into social
programs but that thinking has become
another casualty of the war in ukraine
alan fisher al jazeera on capitol hill